This is Germany in the 1980s.
Before the Berlin Wall came down.
Still fractured in two between two world superpowers,
and this is the map of Nuclear Power plants
that powered the country.
The 1980s was an eventful time period for
this recovering nation.
Chernobyl, located here, just north of Kiev,
exploded.
Showering Europe in radioactive material.
The severity of the incident can be hard to
grasp in hindsight.
Iodine tablets were distributed across Europe.
An emergency preventative medicine to ensure
that the thyroid gland is saturated in non-radioactive
iodine, preventing it from absorbing the radioactive
iodine present in nuclear fallout.
Where it could fester and cause cancer.
The fallout from Chernobyl spread on westerly
winds across Europe.
And the news spread even faster.
The people of Europe were afraid.
“Local people received 7.4 milligrays an
hour of radiation
Radioactive cesium is recycling in the moss
Because I have been thinking all day about
this radiation radiation and nothing more
The chernobyl disaster could reap a bitter
harvest for the peasant farmers of Poland's
far north east
If the worst has already happened, the first
cases of leukemia should be appearing now.”
Chernobyl was given the highest ranking on
the International Nuclear Event Scale.
A 7, a major accident with a large release
of radioactive materials.
Or, in less technical terms, Europe was crop
dusted in cancer dust.
[1]
This event, understandably, put a massive
dent in support for nuclear energy across
the world.
But, this wasn’t the genesis of the anti-nuclear
movement in Germany.
In 1975, 30,000 protestors occupied the construction
site of a new nuclear power plant in south
western Germany, on the border with France.
In 1979, 7 years before chernobyl, 200,000
protestors took to the streets of Germany
after the 3 Mile Island nuclear disaster in
the United States.
The anti-nuclear movement in Germany was a
grassroots movement, led by the people, and
driven by fears of the very real danger nuclear
energy poses.
There was a tremendous amount of political
pressure to begin phasing out these plants,
and these protests led directly to the creation
of Germany’s Green Party in 1980.
The Chernobyl accident of 1986 simply strengthened
the support for the Greens political ideology.
To phase out nuclear energy completely.
In 1998, the Green Party came into power for
the first time, and the true end of nuclear
power in Germany was all but secured.
It was decided that no new nuclear power generators
would be built in the country from then forward,
and in 2002 a law banning new nuclear energy
was passed.
With two nuclear power plants being taken
offline prematurely in Germany soon after.
Angela Merkel, and her opposition party the
CDU, called these deactivations “destruction
of national property”
However, in the wake of the Fukushima Disaster,
even Merkel's opposition to the anti-nuclear
movement began to falter.
Fukushima is the only other incident in the
history of nuclear power that was ranked on
par with Chernobyl, receiving the highest
ranking possible due to its impact on the
environment and the people of Japan.
The Green Party’s power in Germany was now
at an all time high, winning control in influential
and powerful states in the south of Germany
for the first time.
The anti-nuclear movement was too large a
political football, or perhaps nuclear football,
to ignore, and Merkel’s CDU party joined
the anti-nuclear movement.
Nuclear Energy had lost this war, and the
final nuclear power plants in Germany began
to flicker out.
On April 15th 2023.
The final nuclear power plant was shut down.
Holding on through the energy crisis caused
by Russia’s invasion on Ukraine, it finally
met its planned end.
The images of protestors, celebrating the
end of their 50 year war on nuclear energy,
were met with anger and disgust by pro-nuclear
activists online.
Mirroring Merkal’s “destruction of national
property” outrage in the early 2000s.
How could you celebrate something that so
clearly harms Germany’s goals of clean energy.
Shutting its nuclear facilities has caused
Germany to be far more dependent on fossil
fuel than its neighbor France.
This is what a typical day in France looks
like.
Baseload is provided by nuclear energy.
Providing 65-75% of the country's power depending
on the time of day.
Wind, Solar and Hydro play their part too,
with a small amount of flexible gas powered
plants available to quickly ramp up when called
upon.
Releasing just 30-40 grams of carbon dioxide
per kilowatt hour generated.
France is in a group of few.
An industrial giant.
Energy independent.
Not reliant on foreign imports of fossil fuels.
And not just powering its own country on low
carbon energy,
It also supports its own economy by exporting
massive quantities of this power to its neighbors
through high voltage interconnections.
A rare example of a country with few fossil
fuel resources of its own becoming an energy
exporter.
Germany couldn’t be any more different.
Germany emits 440 grams of carbon dioxide
per kilowatt hour generated.
Due to the fact that 20-25% of Germany’s
power comes from environmentally disastrous
coal.
With a further 10-15% coming from gas.
With the remaining power coming from wind,
solar and biomass.
While Germany does receive a large percentage
of its power from renewables, without adequate
energy storage or a nuclear base load, the
country has become extremely dependent on
fossil fuels.
This dependance became all the more apparent
as natural gas imports from Russia were cut
off, causing electricity prices to skyrocket
across Europe.
This feels like a blatant own goal.
A 10 fold increase in carbon emissions.
German’s aren’t ignorant of the damage
coal is having on their environment either.
Expansions of coal mines have been protested
too, and the Green Party of Germany has been
under fire for its vote of approval for an
expansion of an open pit mine.
If there has ever been an icon of industry
driven climate change it has to be the colossal
bucket excavators that roam this mine.
[2] The German government has expressed a
desire to phase out coal power soon, but their
only realistic option to do that currently
is to import even more natural gas.
One thing needs to be acknowledged in this
debate.
Both sides of this argument ultimately want
the same end goal.
Clean, safe sustainable energy.
We are on the same team.
The disagreement is on what is considered
clean and safe.
This exact argument went to the European Parliament
in 2022, where France fought for EU legislation
to label Nuclear Energy and Natural Gas to
be labeled green.
That second part will sound strange, but natural
gas does play a vital role in expanding renewables
in the absence of suitable energy storage.
That subject needs an entire video to itself
to explain.
This legislation divided the European Union,
with 328 votes for and 278 against.
The success of the legislation angered many,
with politicians labeling it as “an odious
greenwashing attempt with Macron (the French
President) as conductor” [3]
Clearly this is a divisive issue, and GreenPeace
is currently trying to sue the EU over it,
but this legislation paves the way for more
countries to emulate what France has done
and invest more money into nuclear energy
while meeting EU mandated sustainable energy
targets.
[4].
France, on the surface, feels like the gold
standard of climate policy.
[5] But, let’s take a deeper look at how
this came to be, and the challenges France
is facing in maintaining this energy policy.
For that we need to rewind 50 years.
It’s 1973.
Egyptian and Syrian forces have launched a
surprise attack on Israel on the Jewish holiday
of Yom Kippur in an attempt to recapture land
on the Sinai peninsula, taken from Egypt in
1967 during the Six Day War.
Western allies of Israel rushed to support
their counter offensives, and in retaliation
the union of Arab oil exporters embargoed
exports to these countries, causing oil prices
worldwide to skyrocket.
Despite France not being a target of these
embargoes, it was a wakeup call for the powerful
country.
With few energy resources of its own, its
economy was extremely vulnerable to outside
manipulation.
Nuclear Energy was the answer, and from 1974
onwards nuclear energy capacity rapidly grew.
cutscene of nuclear power plants coming online
and capacity rising.
[6]
Over the course of these 23 years France increased
its nuclear capacity at an impressive rate
building 56 reactors in 19 different locations.
However, new builds stopped abruptly in the
wake of Chernobyl, with only two new reactors
beginning construction in the aftermath of
this disaster.
Civaux 1 and 2, taking 8 and 9 years to complete.
They came online in 1997 and 1999.
These are the youngest nuclear power plants
in France.
24 and 26 years old.
The oldest nuclear power plant currently is
the Bugey 2 reactor.
Brought online in 1978, it is now 45 years
old.
Its older sibling, Bugey 1 began operation
in 1972, and was decommissioned in 1994.
It was an obsolete design, graphite moderated
and cooled with carbon dioxide.
It needed to be decommissioned for safety
reasons.
Nuclear power plants typically have a life
expectancy between 20 and 40 years, which
poses a problem to the French national grid,
and the European grid at large,
I listed every nuclear power reactor in France
on this excel sheet, and was honestly shocked
when I hit the averaging function.
The average age of nuclear reactors in France
is now 39 years old, and these aging reactors
are beginning to cause some major headaches.
In 2022, in the midst of an energy crisis
triggered by Russia’s invasion of Ukraine,
France’s energy utility provider, the EDF,
was ordered by the country's nuclear watchdog
to inspect all plants after a 23 millimeter
deep crack was found in a 27 mm thick cooling
pipe which circulates low level radioactive
cooling water to the reactor.[7]The cracks
formed as a result of thermal fatigue in a
weld seam, where heating and cooling cycles
caused the pipe to expand and contract.
This crack could have ruptured the pipe at
any moment, and its presence raised alarm
bells for the state of nuclear energy in the
country, and subsequent cracks were found
at other reactors.
In the aftermath of these discoveries nuclear
energy output for the country fell to a 34
year low while these plants were taken offline
for inspection and repairs.
This problem was a result of decades of under
investment and mismanagement of nuclear energy
in France, and to make matters worse, the
technical skills needed to fix the issue have
faded from existence in France as a result
of the 30 year gap in nuclear energy investments
and construction.
France is now rushing to invest and support
welding schools to bring back this important
skill.
[8] And they need it desperately.
Now, just as the Yom Kippur war woke France
up to its energy situation, the war in Ukraine
and these power outages are encouraging political
movement.
France has begun a frantic reinvestment cycle
into nuclear energy.
Just a few days after narrowly escaping an
ousting from Government through an unsuccessful
no-confidence vote, a new nuclear energy investment
plan won a landslide victory.
Gaining bipartisan support, the plan will
see 56 billion dollars be poured into building
6 next generation EPR2 nuclear reactors.
[9]
The first generation EPR began construction
in north western France in 2007.
Over 16 years ago.
When the average age of French nuclear reactors
was just 21 years old.
It still hasn’t delivered any power, and
is nearly 5 times over budget at 13.2 billion
dollars.
A far cry from the 3 billion dollars and 8
year construction time originally quoted.
[10]
The second generation design has been specifically
redesigned to address these cost and construction
issues.
The design challenge of making these nuclear
reactors safe, with all the knowledge we have
gained from accidents over the years, is immense.
This is not an isolated incident.
This study states that out of 180 nuclear
construction projects, 175 of them overran
cost estimations.
Costing on average 117 percent more than estimated,
and taking 64 percent more time than projected.
[11]
The latest delay of this new reactor was due
to simple welding issues again.
When even your welds require specialized heat
treatments, requiring specialized skilled
laborers, and stringent safety checks, it’s
going to cause headaches.
The reality is, Nuclear Energy keeps getting
more expensive as new safety standards are
realized with each accident that occurs.
While renewable energy keeps getting cheaper.
The first of the six next generation EPR2
reactors will not begin construction until
May 2027.
Optimistically, they will take about 8 years
to construct at which point the average age
of nuclear reactors in France will be 49 years
old.
Aging nuclear reactors, to say the least,
are not ideal.
Posing major reliability issues as we have
already seen, but a potentially disastrous
safety hazard too.
France is staring down the barrel of major
electrical grid instabilities due to decades
of under investment in nuclear energy.
Nuclear energy, when done right, is clearly
the best solution to reduce carbon dioxide
emissions that we have right now, but the
problem is, it frequently isn’t done right.
So, we have to ask ourselves.
Does Germany have a point?
Were they right to close these nuclear reactors
down?
Or perhaps a middle ground between France
and Germany was needed.
Slowly ramping down nuclear energy while developing
new renewable energy resources with the energy
storage needed to create a stable grid
Or perhaps we need to acknowledge the fact
that nuclear energy as it stands is not viable
long term, and we need to invest in future
technologies that make it safer, cleaner and
cheaper.
The reactor still under construction in France,
as it stands, has a cost of 8 million dollars
per Megawatt.
While wind turbines cost between 1 and 2 million
dollars per megawatt, and critically, they
can be installed gradually without having
to commit billions to a single project.
In a sense, wind turbines are modular.
Smaller, cheaper, easy to replace.
One future tech being worked on right now
aims to give nuclear energy this same advantage.
Small modular nuclear reactors aim to make
smaller reactors that generate less power,
but can have additional modules added over
time to increase capacity.
Reducing initial capital investment, making
it easier to replace aging modules, and allowing
the reactors to be placed in locations not
suitable for larger traditional power plants.
There are several companies working on these
designs now, and in the next episode of Real
Engineering we deep dive into these technologies.
Until then you may want to get ahead of the
game.
I get asked by engineering students pretty
frequently if I have any advice for how to
do well in college.
And I only really have two bits of advice
that I think is applicable to every person.
First, get to know your teachers, they want
to help you and experienced and well connected
friends are how you get opportunities in life.
Second, get ahead of your peers.
Students get a huge amount of time off in
the summer and most, including myself, wasted
it.
I spent my summers enjoying my free time,
but I mostly wasted it playing computer games
and partying.
Until I struggled to get a job after college
I didn’t realize how much time I wasted.
Once I got accepted into my masters program
and decided to change how I approach life.
I asked the head of the aeronautical program
what the most difficult subjects were, and
if I could get a copy of the textbooks early.
He sent them out and I came into my stability
and control classes ahead of everyone else.
It enabled me to help my classmates and make
friends and allowed me to concentrate on projects
when time was tight in exam season.
Teaching yourself isn’t easy though, however
I have a solution to that.
Brilliant.
An excellent platform that can help you brush
up on the essentials of engineering.
It uses interactive courses that test your
knowledge along the way.
A platform designed to teach you difficult
subjects in the most efficient way possible.
Using visual interactive examples, and they
don’t impede your progress when you struggle.
If you can’t figure out an answer, you can
open an in depth explanation and move onto
the next section.
You can try it out for free to see whether
you like it, but the first 500 people to sign
up with my link will get 20% off Brilliant's
annual premium subscription
I would highly recommend completing every
course on the advanced mathematics syllabus
on Brilliant.
Every single one of these will give you an
edge in understanding engineering concepts.
If you aren’t comfortable diving in this
deep, there is a mathematics fundamentals
syllabus that will get you there.
Second, learn python.
It can help you automate things to make your
life easier and it is used in a lot of engineering
software.
I used it in my master thesis to create plugins
for abaqus, an engineering modeling software
for testing designs.
I struggled to teach it to myself when I needed
it, and I wish I just came into my masters
already knowing it.
If you’ve never done any coding before,
you can check out their new course Thinking
in Code, which will help you understand the
basics of how computer programs work.
Then once you’ve mastered the basics, Brilliant
has more advanced python courses too.
These are likely the most universally useful
courses to present and future engineers, but
there are plenty of other courses on Brilliant.
AI, data science, neural networks and more.
You can get access to that course right now,
and all of Brilliant's other curated interactive
courses, by clicking the link in the description
and on screen now.
You can get started for free, and the first
500 people to do so will get 20% off Brilliant's
annual premium subscription